[Music]
despite having very few first-party
exclusives in 2022 Xbox still had a
pretty strong year thanks to some
excellent additions to Xbox game pass
which grew its catalog with dozens of
fantastic games here are the five best
Xbox games of 2022 as selected by
Gamespot as well as five honorable
mentions that you need to check out ASAP
2022 was truly the year of vampire
survivors the Smash Hit bullet hell
Survival game that took Steam and Xbox
by storm while it might not look like a
shiny Triple A release when it comes to
satisfying gameplay Loops that'll keep
you hooked for hours it is unmatched but
what do you do in Vampire survivors you
survive for 30 minutes that's the goal
the moment-to-moment gameplay is
relatively simple all you have to do is
move your character who will then
automatically attack enemies that will
begin to swarm you enemies drop gems
which you then pick up to gain
experience and level up unlocking new
weapons and Buffs it is so simple to
play and the more you do the more the
game gets its hooks in you from fusing
weapons to get more powerful evolved
versions to unlocking every stage and
character to even defeating the Grim
Reaper himself there is so much to do
and it's bite-sized 30 minute stages are
perfect to dip into
pentiment is an adventure game set in
the 16th century you play as Andreas
Marla an artist working for an Abbey in
Bavaria who was also aiming to finish
his Masterpiece on the side a murder at
the Abbey is the spark that lights the
Powder Keg that is the relationship
between the Abbey the townsfolk and The
Peasants and somehow it's up to Andreas
to investigate the conspiracy at the
heart of it all Andreas is a Stranger in
a Strange Land just as we the players
are to a rapidly changing 16th century
Bavarian Society pentiment follows the
role each person as well as the church
plays and to prevent it from being
overwhelming offers an in-depth glossary
and character guide to help out in a
pinch much has been made about
pentiman's art style which is a love
letter to the art of the time but it's
the game's characters that really shine
especially as we see them grow and
change over time if you long to dig into
an intriguing mystery maybe learn some
things too then pentiment is the game
for you
three movies one incredible story when
an actress goes missing it's up to you
to scrub through her three unreleased
movies and behind the scenes footage to
find Clues and try and discover the
truth of what happened to her things
might seem straightforward at first
glance but the deeper you dig the more
secrets you'll uncover immortality
utilizes FMV to tell its story and
features some of the best performances
you'll see all year particularly from
man and Gage who plays the lead role of
Marissa Marcel in his 8 out of 10 review
Mark Delaney wrote despite and sometimes
because of the dizzying effect of
falling down the rabbit hole immortality
becomes another standout narrative it's
similar to its predecessors telling lies
and her story in some key ways but more
thought-provoking too and certainly more
unnerving than you'll be prepared for
grounded is a survival crafting game
with a Twist you're a kid who's been
shrunken down to the size of an ant and
it's up to you and some Pals to survive
in the backyard gather resources build a
base and fend off the creepy crawlies
that are out to get you but everything
is coated with a childlike sense of
adventure making it feel more like Honey
I Shrunk the Kids or the borrowers
grounded has been in the Xbox Early
Access program for a couple of years but
hit 1.0 in 2022 in his 8 out of 10
review Mark Delaney said the Fantastical
setup makes for an immediately
intriguing setup and to further stylize
it as a uniquely childlike Adventure
polish it Beyond most of its peers and
set it in a world full of familiar
sights to see in startling new ways
makes grounded no small feat
as dusk Falls is an interactive
narrative game that follows the Fallout
of a robbery gone wrong and how the
event impacts the lives of two families
in small town Arizona your decisions
have consequences and the outcomes for
the characters vary wildly depending on
the choices that you make if that sounds
like too much pressure get some friends
involved to help out as you can play the
game with up to eight friends both
online and locally in his 9 out of 10
review Mark Delaney wrote by way of
incredible voice acting a compelling and
expertly written script and a bounty of
pause-worthy choices along the game's
elaborate branching paths it establishes
itself as an instant classic in the
narrative Adventure genre those were
gamespot's 5 best Xbox games of 2022 but
since you've been good this year here
are five more if you're a fan of Pikmin
you'll feel right at home with tinykin
as Milo an astronaut who has crash
landed in a house it's up to you to
gather Little Critters called tinykin to
help you get home a tinykin by itself
can't do much but when you gather a
small group together you can alter them
to lift heavy items break items that are
in your way and even make currents to
power on electronics tinykin is a
delightful puzzle platformer where
ordinary items have multiple uses and
there's a secret tucked behind every
corner each of tinykins levels is set in
a different room of a 90s era Family
Home and with your tiny kin you're
tasked with various objectives from the
bugs who call the house home getting
around the large spaces is a breeze not
only can you Glide using your bubble
pack but you can also speed around on a
bar of soap which is just as fun and
satisfying as it sounds in her 8 out of
10 review Jess Howard said tinykin is a
delightful callback to 90s
collect-a-thons and Platformers with
just the right amount of new ideas and
iterations
okay okay I know Elden ring is not an
XBox exclusive by any means because it
also came out on PC and Playstation but
it did win our game of the year award
and it's a game you should be playing
regardless of which platform you own
sorry switch owners because Elden ring
is from software's magnum opus and will
go down in history as one of the best
open world if not one of the best games
of all time as a lowly tarnished you
awaken in the lands between an enormous
world full of mystery Discovery and
danger and must fight your way to become
the Elden Lord in typical from software
the journey is punishing but Elden ring
takes a lot of strides in becoming the
most approachable from soft game yet if
an encounter is too difficult for you
there is a whole world to explore full
of hundreds of weapons and spells to
create a build that works for you in his
10 out of 10 review Timor Hussein wrote
from software's latest is a masterpiece
of open world design that places
exploration and player agency at the
heart of the experience that delicate
orchestration of highs and lows and the
build up and release of tension that
from software has mastered coupled with
the thrill of freeform exploration and
Discovery is an intoxicating cocktail of
game design
Beacon Pines is a game with an
incredibly intriguing premise the game
is set within a book and you play the
role of both the book's main character
and its reader along the adventure you
collect golden charms which can then be
used to replace specific words in the
story which then changes how things play
out Beacon Pines is a unique take on the
choice driven narrative genre and
manages to balance being cute and creepy
all at the same time so what more could
you want
and nobody saves the world you're a
nobody and that's okay when an ancient
threat called the Calamity awakens it's
up to you to stop it by transforming
into a creature that's up to the task
whether that's a ghost horse dragon or
even a slug Yes you heard that right you
can swap forms to use abilities suitable
for the situation you're in as you
complete quests you level up each form
and unlock new ones providing a
compelling gameplay Loop where the next
unlock is always around the corner mix
that with the procedurally generated
Dungeons and nobody Saves the World As a
Dungeon Crawler that offers so much
variety that it's tough to put it down
in his 9 out of 10 review Steve Watts
was enamored with the game saying after
finishing nobody Saves the World I went
right back to it there were still
dungeons to explore powers to unlock
secrets to uncover and a new game plus
mode to conquer when a game is this much
frictionless fun it's hard to resist a
plague tale Requiem is the sequel to
2019's a plague tale innocence and once
again follows amicia and her little
brother Hugo as they desperately search
cure for Hugo's disease the game is set
in France where a deadly plague is being
carried by rats and it's not just the
bite that you need to avoid soldiers of
the Inquisition are constantly on your
tail hoping to use Hugo's condition for
their own gains a plague tale Requiem is
a finely crafted puzzle action adventure
game with a deeply affecting story about
siblings at its heart it's not truly an
XBox exclusive but it did launch as a
day one game pass title earlier this
year
those were our picks for the best Xbox
games of 2022 if you want to know the
best PlayStation switch and PC games of
the year make sure to subscribe to
Gamespot on YouTube or check out
gamespot.com we also have an in-depth
video on our game of the year Elden ring
and just why it got that coveted title
you can find me on Twitter at Lucy James
games and I'll see you next time
thank you
[Music]